damit der banken angedacht hollywood
wasser
murat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen zum
meine zuschauer
ich habe nicht viel zeit deswegen kann
ja gar nicht viel erklären ich mache
jetzt hier mein lieblingsrezept und zwar
das rezept mache ich immer meine jungs
fußball schaue dass ich gelogen hat sich
das chris hat mir nie gemacht mein
freund gesagt sie das machen
deswegen mache ich das jetzt ja wieder
seine moral mit minister nils berger
machen genau cheeseburger muffins das
können auch männer machen
ganz einfach sagt ich brauche hier 500
gramm hackfleisch also für die füllung
brauchen fünf gramm hackfleisch zwiebeln
dann zwei esslöffel salz an halben sc
hinten war es exakt die menge nicht
erzählt das ist völlig okay also ich
habe ja jetzt in fleisch zwiebeln salz
zucker dieses thymian pfeffer
entschuldigung was pfeffer
dann habt ihr noch käse mit knoblauch
zwei esslöffel ist weiß ich das ist sam
dann habt ihr hier zweifel tomatenmark
dann habt ihr hier zwei esslöffel
olivenöl von glücklichen oliven dann
habe ich hier noch catcher okay das ist
nicht gesund aber muss auch nicht so und
die genaue rezept angaben schreibt euch
sally rein genau dann haben wir hier
noch nachher für für das wird mir das
los darüber macht wie verpacken ja also
überbacken für das gewachsene habe ich
wieder da und da habe ich hier
essiggurken so fangen wir gleich an
olivenöl erhitzen so olivenöl rein dann
während es hier an dreht und halt damit
gehe ich schon mal zur zwiebel schneiden
die zwiebel hier kann ich einem
ähnliches messer schwarze socken
da fange ich an zu schneien
[Musik]
das soll jetzt nämlich die zwiebel aber
ich bin ich bin natürlich ein sauberer
mann ich komme gleich wieder aufmacht
weg
dann nämlich die zwiebel hier ein hier
werde ich mich einfach drauf sagt ach du
schreck war bis jetzt ist ja keine ist
ist egal oder
ok
knoblauch song und knoblauch schneide
ich auch das war nicht immer so dass
irgendwas gleich rein schnell
ich brauche ein spargel ich muss runter
schalten und das spritzt von 1 megawatt
ich komme immer ein neues werkzeug so
jetzt noch mal die knoblauch die ist
geschehen
die mache ich jetzt auch hier rein
verständlich dass jetzt gratis an
während er sich das anbraten krämer mit
alkohol
das ist der pizzateig oder sally und von
den pizzateig genaue mengen die wirklich
sally bekannt und wie gesagt das könnte
auf sally ihrem kanal einfach sallys
pizzateig eingeben anschauen ich will es
die hälfte hier raus vom titel
geht nicht so viel ich kann ständig
ausrollen
mit dem ausbau startet die hände einmal
so ja jetzt weiß wie es ist und jetzt
ausholen orange ist nicht viel mehr
ach gott so und jetzt hole ich ihn aus
der optik bieten
ok ok vergewaltiger den teig naja
dankeschön
jetzt habe ich ihn ausstecher ihr könnt
aber auch ein glas guten glas
marmeladenglas und glas unternehmen zum
ausstechen und jetzt schlecht ich genau
so aus dass ich dann rein kriegen
ich habe jetzt komisch an aber zeigen
euch jetzt so jetzt fangen wir einfach
hier unten an dass man sich das nachher
aus jetzt werden die ganze backform 1
3 und jetzt tue ich das hier ein eigenes
ich mache jetzt doch er steht gelungen
fertig ja ich mache erst fertig soll das
falsche schön angebraten jetzt tue ich
noch die 23 und den knoblauch jetzt tue
ich noch den teffer salz und zucker und
den zugab ich rein getan weil man es mit
zubereiten kann sally manche zogen
gemacht im ausgleichen gerade seine
aussagen genau zum ausgleich
genau und jetzt habe ich es zu einer
homogenen masse was sagen das hört sich
so intelligent an kann ich sagen dass
ich nicht um renault mégane ja ok als
nächstes manchen sempt rein und dann
habe ich noch zwei esslöffel tomatenmark
rein nur 20 gramm tomatenmark zack zack
zack
jetzt gebe ich noch zwei esslöffel
ketchup hinzu das waren 2 ist
tomatenketchup jetzt höre ich das schön
nachdem ich das gemacht habe nämlich in
den keller
sack hatte darunter stellen auf 2 oder 3
und während ich das mache die hin und zu
den teig in die förmchen rein und ich
habe gut eingebettet wird noch mal
sicher sicher ist ich muss auch andere
leute mal was machen lassen so während
sally das macht natürlich weiter und den
räumen des zeugen in den kühlschrank
ich glaube der kreis ist ein bisschen zu
klein kann es sein
[Musik]
wir brauchen noch acht stück für stück
ist hoch acht kreise also macht jetzt
ungefähr zu hause darf seine frau
arbeiten ja ich probiere die füllung
ich habe mir simple also jetzt mache ich
eine scheibe blockieren
ja ich denke sie rein so ok sie wollten
haben genau wie passt jetzt nämlich die
füllung und hatten ja ich nehme ein eis
portion er damit das hackfleisch in die
führung reinbringen
[Musik]
genauer eindrücken damit der teig am
rand hoch geht auf die welt gekommen ein
schlafraum muss ich ehrlich sagen
schlaue frau jetzt durch die story im
backofen und kurz vor allem der backzeit
hole ich schon mal raus dann belege ich
das nochmal mit einem tollen keller käse
darüber und ein bisschen ketchup und das
bist du bereit für ein paar minuten und
das ist richtig kostet okay so ganz
einfach sagt so jetzt habe ich den
braten in die röhre
[Musik]
das war ein bisschen ketchup braucht das
lasse ich nicht optional der clip nicht
mal braucht noch keinen kitsch abnehmen
was anderes machen so jetzt nämlich in
cadaqués dem keller käse
den habe ich jetzt hier oben so drauf
richtig cool sagt drücke und dass du
jetzt wieder im backofen und lassen es
schön schmelzen für die nächsten drei
minuten
[Musik]
da die firma voraus ist ja ich habe
nichts anderes erwartet muss ich ehrlich
sagen so und jetzt muss raus ok mit was
wollen wir es raus ich ihm eine palette
ok ansonsten eine palette weg eine
palette habt habt ein problem aber das
kriegt auch immer die gerichte ist
gemacht habe sage als energie-kommissar
ausgehen so auf jeden fall jetzt ein
bisschen unterhalten sie noch gebraucht
ja das gehört noch nach probieren ja
jetzt ist man die serie grand probiert
aber bitte sofort bei 300 grad so wie
ich das auch machen muss sally du hast
es zerstört schweisgut ehrlich schmeckt
sehr gut
okay es ist nicht gesund ich muss
zugeben ich bin nicht der beste koch ich
merke erst mal wie meine frau immer zu
kämpfen zu tun hat mich echt wien
schießt lager in einem mafia aktion
schon mega lecker ehrlich jetzt auf
jeden fall am besten schreibt er in die
kommentare
wer möchte dass morath weiter macht ja
es war einmal im monat oder alle zwei
wochen ein rezept genau und nicht so mit
sowie zutaten da komm ich durcheinander
bei der arbeit habe ich nur zwei knöpfe
einmal roten einmal grün dann komme ich
schon durcheinander und weil sowie
zutaten bis wissen schwer
dann fängt man kamera ok also vielen
dank fürs zuschauen
macht's besser bis dann
[Musik]